we play tick-tock videos on the show uh
frequently
and oftentimes they're
they're always deranged and disturbing
but but sometimes in a somewhat funny
way
this is uh not a funny one of course
this is not one we can laugh about
it is ludicrous in the extreme but it's
not at all funny
um here is a mother who took this video
put it proudly on tick tock uh showing
how she is like a munchausen by proxy
situation
how she is trying to impose gender
dysphoria
on her innocent little daughter let's
watch
are you a boy are you a girl
[Music]
what makes you think that
[Music]
mommy can i get this
okay so a little hard to hear there if
you're listening on the audio podcast
especially with the with the music
which just makes this so much
sicker uh that music in the background
but
the video is of a girl six years old
and the mother is like interrogating her
and she's got the camera out she's
recording it uh oh and there's there's
words on the screen says my six-year-old
daughter asks me
if i think she looks like a boy and i
asked her do you want to look like a boy
her response left me speechless
speechless as if she had some profound
response to that she didn't in fact
what she said originally was this what
actually there was there was one
profound
thing that that the child said
uh she said earlier in the video i don't
know who i
am and the mother is
pushing her along guiding her along
towards gender confusion
and uh then she says something like i i
think i'm a boy i feel like a boy
but what she said there i don't know who
i am
that is about as true a statement as a
six-year-old child can ever make
and it's a profound truth a child at
that age
doesn't know who they are
and she is at some level aware that she
doesn't know who she is
which is very interesting um
and maybe that awareness comes from
having a parent who's obsessed with
identity and always trying to impose
these things and so this
this this child appears to like feel all
kids are confused about their identity
and who they are
all kids are um this is something they
come to understand gradually with age
but she is aware of her own confusion
more
mostly because she has an abusive mother
psychologically abusive mother
um but i don't know who i am
and then and then she settles oh i think
i'm a boy
but all you have to do is watch that
video and you can see
that really what you're dealing with
here there's no mystery
there's nothing at all it's this is a
child
who is basically babbling nonsensically
touches on a few truths here and there i
don't know who i am
but for the most part as kids do at that
age
and for years thereafter kind of
babbling
saying words doesn't really know exactly
what you're saying
and what do these parents do they seize
on that
confusion and they exploit it
and then they and then they they take
these children they put them on display
for the whole world to see
that mother by the way i did look up her
uh tiktok account
and she uh was responding to some of the
critics and of course she was making a
victim of herself
so i wasn't expecting i was expecting
all this this big response and
and tried to defend and and and make a
victim of herself
but she she's so surprised that this
video got a lot of attention and she was
being criticized for it
and rightly so yeah well
if you didn't want attention then why
did you put it online
this is the other thing these parents
always do which sends me through the
roof
is they put their child on display for
the whole world
they publicize this stuff even though
nobody asked them to
and then when when people share their
opinions
the parents will retreat back to this is
our private life it's none of your
business
stay out of our lives if it's none of
our business
why are you telling us about it
see when you put something out there
into into the public domain for everyone
to see
you're going to get people's opinions
we're allowed to have opinions opinions
about anything
any information you give me i am going
to have an opinion about it because i
have a brain and i'm allowed to
if you don't want my opinion about it
don't tell me about it
no they want our opinion
it's just that they want our opinion to
validate
the psychological trauma and abuse that
they are
imposing on their child that's what they
want
and when they they don't get that then
they uh then then they become the
victims because as i always point out
this is all about the parent it's got
nothing to do with the kid
the the children are spectators
you know
in a weird way the children become
spectators of their own
identity crisis as the parents
create this identity crisis on their own
and the kids are just sitting back
looking at it like what is
what's mom doing what is what's
happening right now
[Music]
absolutely disgusting hey listen
hit the subscribe button do it right now
i
demand it and i thank you for your
compliance it is somewhat
appreciated